Florida Governor Ron DeSantis has sent
the entire American left into a tizzy
and now days-long National meltdown how
did he do it
he approached 50 of the 2 million
illegal aliens per year the Democrats
invite into this country he gave 50 of
them 5-0
airplane tickets to Martha's Vineyard
the fact that that Fox News and not the
Department of Homeland Security the city
or local ngos were alerted about a plan
to leave migrants including children on
the side of a busy DC Street makes clear
that this is just a cool premeditated
political stunt this is what they are
doing and a couple more things the
migrants including children
who arrived in Martha's Vineyard were
misled about where they were being taken
and what would be provided when they
arrived is also deeply alarming the
children Governor Abbott abandoned in
Martha's Vineyard the children that the
that that Governor DeSantis abandoned as
well
um
you know deserve better
they deserve better than being left on
the streets of DC or being left in
Martha's Vineyard they deserve deserve a
lot better than that
yeah these people deserve better than to
be left on the streets of Washington DC
or Martha's Vineyard they deserve to be
left in the streets of El Paso right
isn't that so much better she also keeps
saying it's the children it's the
children it's adults it's adult people
who have come to America flocking some
children come to America too Democrats
have invited millions and millions of
people per year and it's it's good right
it's good to leave them there right
there on the border it's just bad
to leave them in Martha's Vineyard I
don't mean to disparage El Paso I like
Texas as much as the next guy but I
don't see very many prominent Democrats
wealthy liberal Elites buying property
on the border do you I don't see many
wealthy liberals vacationing in El Paso
or Del Rio
I see them all flocking to Martha's
Vineyard which they boast is a sanctuary
for illegal aliens
so great that's a win-win right the
illegal aliens come in and Texas says to
Florida Arizona they say we're not a
sanctuary so okay send them up to some
of the most desirable property in the
world which says it is a sanctuary great
right apparently not
the liberal journalist Soledad O'Brien
summed up the opposition
basically human trafficking she tweeted
cheered on by people who call themselves
Christians it's disgusting
but if Republicans bringing 50 illegal
aliens to Martha's Vineyard constitutes
human trafficking
what do you call it when Democrats bring
2 million illegal aliens per year into
border states and then by the way what
do you call it when Democrats do exactly
the same thing that DeSantis did except
in regular consistent much larger
numbers we've got the headlines right
here if the problem is that DeSantis is
flying illegal aliens around the country
just 50 of them what about what about
this headline
Biden sent
70 secret night flights of migrants from
border to Florida that's from the
Washington examiner what about this
headline
Biden Administration resumes migrant
flights to Suburban New York report
that's in Fox News okay you might say
well those are well the examiner's not
right wing but you know okay Fox News
that's a sort of vaguely right-wing
website what about NBC news I got NBC
news right here Biden Administration
again flying migrants who cross border
in one place to another before expelling
them okay what about this NBC headline a
mid-border surge Biden Administration
plans to send migrants to cities deeper
inside U.S starting with LA say internal
documents
now why is it that when Republicans do
at a very very small minuscule level
exactly the same thing Democrats have
done at a huge level that's human
trafficking in a way I guess it is human
trafficking
in a way democrats for coming up on 60
years now have trafficked tens of
millions of illegal aliens into America
exposing them by the way to all manner
of horrific violence on the journey and
violating America's most basic laws in
the process
then when Democrats feel like they've
got enough illegals in border states
they fly the migrants to other parts of
the country where they think that
they'll be more politically useful and
then all the while it's lauded as
virtuous and compassionate and as
American as apple pie and then
the moment Republicans send even a few
dozen of those very same migrants to the
neighborhoods of wealthy Democrats all
of a sudden it's a crime against
humanity
Beach season is over there are now lots
of multi-million dollar Mansions owned
by open borders Democrats all over
Martha's Vineyard there are ample
opulent accommodations just waiting to
be occupied by people to whom the owners
of those homes promised Sanctuary back
when they thought it was impossible that
the migrants would actually show up for
it I for one say it's time to open up
the doors of those wealthy Democrats
homes to all that diversity and strength
show those selfish border state
Republicans what true compassion looks
like and Governor DeSantis keeps sending
those lucky illegal aliens up to the
vineyard for a luxury vacation the
Democrats will never forget I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Big Daddy
Scoops who says Trump
go down and peacefully protest
is apparently a call for violence
Democrats this is a call to Arms well
that is totally necessary that's good
that's safe that's of course that's true
of course that's true when Republicans
do anything that's violent that's
extreme that's terrorism that's a threat
to our sacred democracy when Democrats
actually call on their supporters
to confront attack and even kill
Republicans well that's safe that's
constitutionally protected that's that's
really democracy in action
are you getting it now are you are you
catching on I suspect you are catching
on I suspect a lot of other people who
are not paying as close attention are
catching on to we got to keep our
country safe we got to keep our homes
safe that's why you need ring right now
go to ring.com Knowles we are in speech
season baby I travel a whole lot I yeah
but I'm always traveling a lot you might
be too you got your summer vacations
then you're going back to work and then
you want to make sure that your home is
protected that's why you need a ring did
you know that ring has a wonderful alarm
system I know you're thinking Ring the
video doorbell company yeah they have an
alarm they have an award-winning home
security system with available
professional monitoring when you
subscribe best of all you can easily
install it yourself and ring does not
stop there
they've changed the entire home security
game with ring alarm Pro that is why I
have teamed up with ring and when it
comes to protecting our home you gotta
go pro baby you gotta be a pro like me
okay ring alarm Pro is whole home
security with available professional
monitoring when you subscribe to ring
protect Pro ring alarm Pro combines a
security system with a fast Euro Wi-Fi 6
router so you're protecting your
physical home and your digital home as
well all with one device it's absolutely
phenomenal protect your home be like me
GoPro with ring alarm Pro you can do it
too okay learn more at ring.com Knowles
that is ring.com Knowles
not in my backyard that is the Democrats
immigration policy oh yeah open up that
border as long as it's down in El Paso
as long as it's down in Del Rio as long
as they're going to Florida as long as
the Biden Administration can fly the
migrants to wherever they're politically
useful
maybe look maybe they'll end up in some
blue cities only some small number of
them all right we'll tolerate that I
guess
but they sure as hell ain't coming to
Martha's Vineyard oh no 50 migrants 50
oh my gosh think of the property values
though oh could you imagine and then
there might be a line you know at the
local brunch spot no no no we need to
build a big beautiful wall around
Martha's Vineyard and keep those
migrants out we just have to send them
to Border States
the head of the winter home shelter uh
Lisa Bell Castro she's coordinator there
she just came out and summed up I think
the opinion of Martha's Vineyard
what are the most difficult challenges
right now the difficult challenges are
uh
we have at some point in time they have
to move to the field and somewhere else
right we we cannot we don't have the
services to take care of 50 immigrants
um and we we certainly don't have
housing we're in a housing crisis as we
are on this island and
we don't we can't house everyone here
that lives here and works here we don't
have housing for 50 more people
that's tough sounds like you're gonna
have to build some more housing
sounds like you don't oh you don't have
the services set up well you I guess you
better better get them huh I mean the
federal government spends untold amounts
of money
not only to service illegal immigration
but to actually encourage illegal
immigration so better send some of that
money to Martha's Vineyard
50 people 50. it's nothing it's so few
people that's not a drop of an iota of a
fraction of a of even a slight
percentage point of the illegal
immigration that border states get
so you better figure it out guys oh we
just don't have room what are you
talking about Martha's Vineyard is empty
right now
people leave Martha's Vineyard after
Labor Day
consider the homes that are completely
empty right now
I bet you any home almost any home on
Martha's Vineyard could have that is
empty right now that is owned by some
wealthy liberal Elite could house all of
the migrants that Rhonda Santa sent up
there they just won't do it
because they would much rather have Red
State voters they would much rather have
Republicans in Texas deal with the
consequences of illegal immigration then
in any way even slightly crack open the
doors to their gazillion dollar Mansions
Barack Obama alone
could house every single migrant that
has been sent to Martha's Vineyard
Barack Obama has a 12 million dollar
mansion on Martha's Vineyard it's almost
7 000 square feet it's got seven
bedrooms but even that okay so seven
bedrooms that could that alone could
probably almost house all of the illegal
immigrants to say nothing of the living
rooms and the sitting rooms and the but
Barack Obama's got 30 Acres
this guy has so much land he's got a
separate Barn you can put up a temporary
shelter there you got 30 Acres you could
put up many temporary shelters
every every migrant could get his own
temporary mansion
and he should do it by the way
if if Barack Obama wanted a real
political Master stroke here he would
open up his home he's got the best
security in the world he doesn't need to
worry about that
he's not even there he could open up his
home
allow the 50 migrants in he would look
like an absolute hero who would be such
a master stroke
but he won't do it none of these people
will do it because they don't want they
don't want the dirty filthy Hoy polloi
migrants in their homes they don't want
them in their backyard they'll talk a
really really good game when the
migrants are over a thousand miles away
down on the border but they don't want
these people the only time that the
wealthy Democrats at Martha's Vineyard
are going to allow any Latin Americans
anywhere near them is when they're
mowing their lawns that's what it's all
about and they'll talk a really really
good game but ultimately they don't care
one little wit about these people
they certainly don't care about the
millions of them coming each year they
can't even tolerate being near they
can't even tolerate 50 of them being
near their property
much less their themselves or their
families
and so DeSantis exposes that and gives
these migrants a nice trip to one of the
most desirable locations in the world
great keep it up keep those plane loads
coming baby
we got to do it we got it we gotta make
sure that we all coordinate on this okay
the red State Governors need to
coordinate we all got to talk to each
other when you want to talk you got to
check out pure talk USA right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code at Knowles
podcast Verizon ATT T-Mobile these guys
take way too much of your money every
month for way more data than you will
ever need which is really really
concerning especially given the current
state of the economy no matter what the
libs tell you we are in a recession
right now it is time to hunker down and
start saving money wherever we can one
of the ways you can do that is by
looking at your current cell phone bill
and realizing that you are paying for
way more data than you need if that is
the case and I'm almost certain it is
then you should talk to my friends over
at Pure Talk Pure Talk gives you Myriad
choices so that you can choose the data
plan that is right for you whether that
is two gigs per month or an unlimited
plan with a mobile hotspot by switching
to Pure Talk the average family of four
is saving over seventy five dollars
every month customers are realized using
that they simply do not need as much
data as they thought plus Pure Talk
makes it easy to find the right plan for
you and your family they're a
veteran-owned company with a customer
service team based right here in the US
they make the switch from your current
provider super easy takes 10 minutes do
it right now join the hundreds of
thousands who are making the switch to
pure talk today this month when you
switch to Pure Talk you get one month
free
I have loved Pure Talk for years now
they have never made an offer this big
go to puretalk.com choose your plan
enter code Knowles podcast for this
special offer puretalk.com switch to my
cell phone company enter code Knowles
podcast get your one month free you know
speaking of Mexicans and speaking of
people from Latin America
Switching gears here away from
immigration there was a story just came
out of Mexico that is really really
jarring and should put all Americans on
high alert for what it means for our own
culture because it's coming here as well
a university student in Mexico
is the the school's valedictorian
okay and he's got now his degree and
license to practice psychology and now
all of that is threatened his degree his
license to practice his career is
threatened
because the valedictorian had the
audacity to challenge transgender Theory
and to defend the family
so this guy in his speech
in his valedictory speech makes a really
important basic but really important
point he says
I'll I'll translate into English and
today we are deep into a real
anthropological struggle to redefine the
human being the human person man through
the implementation of ideologies and
Fashions of thought that always end up
undermining dignity and freedom
he then quoted GK Chesterton he said
people do not know what they are doing
because they do not know what they are
undoing and then he said to attack life
in the family is to self-destruct it is
an attack on civilization itself
absolutely true he's right
and now he could lose everything ADF the
alliance defending Freedom which I
strongly support is uh now defending
this young man this is coming here too
and what this really represents is
effectively an outlawing of Christianity
and public life
and coincidentally an outlawing of
Judaism and public life and
coincidentally an outlawing of Islam and
public life and coincidentally an
outlawing of any vaguely traditional
religious moral ethical view on marriage
that's what it is it's an it's an
establishment of
leftism as the state religion
you're seeing it in Mexico you're seeing
it elsewhere in Latin America you're
seeing it all throughout Western Europe
and you're seeing it happen in the
United States this is what the marriage
bill is about I mentioned it a little
briefly at the end of the show yesterday
there's a bill right now
it's being supported by democrats and
squish Republicans Republicans in the
Senate and even some Senate candidates
are volunteering this like Dr Oz The
Biggest Loser running this year he's
saying I'm going to defend this bill
that will not only accept the Supreme
Court's decision to radically redefine
marriage in obergeville but it's going
to enshrine that in federal law and by
the way even if you support a burgerfuel
even if you support redefining marriage
to include same-sex unions
the bill goes much further than that
what the bill does is effectively Outlaw
institutions that have any relation to
the government at all from believing
that marriage is what marriage actually
is and not the insane new definition of
it
what what the marriage bill will do
is say that if you're uh if you're a
501c3 if you're a church if you're a
Civic organization if that you if and
you
in any way support marriage as marriage
actually is
you're going to lose your your tax
exemption you're going to be punished by
the state you're going to be sued by the
government they already did this in
Pennsylvania they did this because a
Catholic charity what a Catholic charity
uh helps facilitate the adoption of
children and because it's a Catholic
charity it doesn't adopt children out to
just anybody it says that children have
a right to a mother and a father and so
the the babies go to married parents you
know husband and wife
uh some gay activists sued and said no
we want the children and we want to
force the Catholic adoption agency to
give children to us goes up to the high
courts
and finally uh the the courts say no
sorry Pennsylvania sorry political
activists in the Pennsylvania government
you don't have the right to ban
Catholicism from your state this law
would do it
this law would do it and it's not even
just this one bill you're seeing it's
not even just this one country you're
seeing it in Mexico too if you even
suggest that maybe we shouldn't redefine
the human person in the family oh yeah
you remember how you were the smartest
person in our class remember you're the
valedictorian you're gonna have a great
career ahead of you we're going to take
it all away we're going to take it all
away because you have the audacity
to be a Christian
or a Jew or a Muslim or just a
reasonable person or you have the
audacity to hold the views on marriage
and the human person that Barack Obama
held in 2011.
that's the stakes that we're talking
about and you've got squish useless
coward morally idiotic Republicans
some of them it's a small minority but
it's some of them who are defending it
it's pathetic
the question we're asking ourselves is
not well who has the right who has the
right to get married or adopt or this or
the right to speak or you're right to
not be offended or this right or that
right or this right really the question
is
what is the animating force of our
country
what is the soul of our country that's
what we're really asking countries have
a physical aspect and a metaphysical
aspect just like a human person we got
our body and we got our soul well the
country is the same way so what is
what is the what is America what we are
told today by the libs is that America
is a liberal democracy we need to defend
liberal democracy and what's really
ironic about this
is that the phrase liberal democracy
appears pretty much nowhere in the
English language until really until 1930
and then it doesn't Spike at all until
really the 1950s and then it really
doesn't take off until 1982. but before
if you if you Google say Christian
Nation
that appears all over the place
Christian civilization Christian country
that's all over the literature you can
see it everywhere liberal democracy
doesn't exist doesn't really take off
until about 40 years ago
so if if liberal democracy is what
America really is at her core and her
Essence uh no one knew it until roughly
four decades ago
the way that America conceived herself
in the beginning the Constitution the
Declaration of Independence The
Federalist Papers you don't see that
phrase liberal democracy
you don't see the phrase democracy all
that much democracy does not appear in
the Constitution or the Declaration of
Independence it does appear in The
Federalist Papers a handful of times
always with disapproval the founding
fathers were very very skeptical of
democracy and the word liberal doesn't
really appear doesn't appear in the
Constitution doesn't appear in the
Declaration of Independence it appears
in the Federalist again a handful of
times but only in the sense of
um generous you know oh he's a very
liberal person it's not referring to any
political philosophy or ideology
by contrast
the word Nation appears in all three of
the documents it appears in The
Federalist Papers I think 569 times
always with approval and then so at the
physical aspect you say Okay America is
a nation
and then what animates the nation what's
the soul of the nation it's not
liberalism if you go back to the
founding documents the founding papers
it's Christianity that's what John Adams
says John Adams says that the thing that
United the founding father is the thing
that United The Men Who Built the
country was the principles of
Christianity that's it sometimes the
libs like to quote this line that they
pretend is from John Adams they say
America is a no way founded on the
Christian religion that line comes from
the Treaty of Tripoli that's that was
signed by John Adams but it was not
written by John Adams it was written by
the Jeffersonian Republican Joel barno I
think his name was and it was it was
just a diplomatic document to placate
the Muslim Pirates Who were abducting
and enslaving American sailors
it was it was like a ransom letter
basically it wasn't a statement of
philosophy or even really law and John
Adams when he was speaking freely and
not trying to Ransom back the the
sailors directly contradicted the Treaty
of AAA and we all know this we know that
America was a Christian Nation going
back to its earliest days 1620 the
Mayflower why did the Pilgrims set sail
on the Mayflower to establish
Christianity
in the new world why did Governor
Winthrop established the Massachusetts
Bay Colony you don't need to scratch
your head we know he told us because he
gave us a speech we're in which he said
that America will be a shining city on a
hill and a model of Christian charity
we see this in the writings of the
founding fathers we see this later on in
American history we see this in the
Francis Scott Keys poem you know the the
Star-Spangled Banner is based on this
poem called The Battle of Fort McHenry
and the the final Stans of it no one
ever remembers the stanza but the final
big conclusion of the poem is oh thus be
it ever when free men shall stand
between their loved home and the war's
desolation blessed with Victory and
peace May the heaven-rescued land praise
the power that hath made and preserved
us a nation then conquer we must when
our cause is just and this be our motto
in God is our trust and the
Star-Spangled Banner and Triumph shall
wave or the land of the free in the home
of the brave
in God is our trust so that poem became
the national anthem it was authorized
for military use in the late 19th
century uh it's acknowledged for
official use by the White House in 1916
I believe and then established as the
national anthem in 1931 with the
approval of the president as well so
with the Congress and the president this
is our national anthem this is our
national motto and God is our trust
Eisenhower added a version of that to
the Pledge of Allegiance one nation
under God and we know that in God In God
We Trust is on all of the U.S currency
okay that's the animating principle all
a long way of saying what is America
it's a Christian Nation
the body of America it's not it's not
just an Empire it's not a city-state the
physical aspect of America is a nation
okay that's what the founders
established
and then the spiritual aspect the
metaphysical aspect the thing that
animates the nation just like the soul
animates the body a body without a soul
is dead a nation without an animating
principle is dead the animating
principle is not liberalism it's not
secularism it's not atheism
traditionally it's Christianity that's
what it is it's just I'm not even saying
that's a good thing or a bad thing I
obviously think it is a good thing I'm
just stating in historical fact that is
irrefutable okay and now there's a major
campaign underway to upend all of that
what the libs want to do is destroy
America as a nation and open up its
borders a nation that doesn't have
borders cannot be a nation at all they
want to turn America into basically just
a tax form for a global Empire and make
us all citizens of the world without any
distinction between our people and other
people
but again a nation that does not make
any distinction between its own citizens
and foreign Nationals is not a nation
there's there's nothing that
distinguishes it as a nation and then at
the metaphysical level what the
Democrats want to do is disestablish
Christianity
is the animating principle of the
country and establish atheism or
secularism or leftism or whatever
the consequences of that are terrible
the reason that the libs are complaining
about Christian nationalism right now I
just gave a long talk on this at the
national conservative conference which
you can find on YouTube
reason that the Democrats are losing
their minds over Christian nationalism
is not because it's a departure from the
American political tradition
they're losing their minds over it
because Christian nationalism is the
American political tradition
the libs hate the American political
tradition and they're trying to upend
the whole thing you know recently the
daily wire was cc'd on an email from
Harry's razors from a Harry's Razor's
customer who was canceling his
subscription and switching to Jeremy's
this is what he wrote
quote dear Harry's I have used and
enjoyed your razors for five years now
and even have a personalized Harry's
handle however I was disappointed to
learn of the circumstances in which your
company disassociated from the daily
wire and specifically from my show as
such I am not giving any more of my
money to you as I think Jeremy Jeremy's
racers.com could find more uses aligned
with the values that I hold dear I will
add that I'm a resident of the United
Kingdom and Jeremy's does not currently
ship outside of the U.S therefore I'm
arranging to have my Jeremy's
subscription sent to my family in the
USA where it will then be sent at an
additional cost to me oh this is great
this is a small price I'm willing to pay
to expressly support those who stand
against woke bullying signed King
Charles III okay no maybe the email was
not written by Britain's new Sovereign
but the understandably frustrated
citizen who did write that was certainly
right about one thing Jeremy can find
more uses for your money aligned with
the values that you hold dear and
frankly razors are just the start we
enjoyed receiving this email so much we
are encouraging you to do the same when
you subscribe to Jeremy's razors copy us
CCS on your breakup email with Harry's
or Gillette maybe we'll read it on the
show just send it to reviews at
jeremy'sraisers.com stop giving your
money to what corporations that hate you
give it to Jeremy instead go to Jeremy's
razors.com today
what has happened to conservatives
we we ask what has happened to the
Liberals my bigger question is what has
happened to the conservatives the way we
talk we sound
today American conservatives send way
more to the left than any of the libs or
the radicals or the Socialists did 10 20
30 years ago how pathetic is that
Dr Oz got me thinking about this because
Dr Oz right now is campaigning as a
republican for Senate far to the left of
Barack Obama just 10 years ago 11 years
ago
but it's not just Dr Oz it's a lot of
other Republicans too how on Earth did
we get here uh Edmund smirk one of my
favorite Twitter accounts pseudonymous
Twitter accounts called my attention to
this it is the radical feminist
Catherine McKinnon back in 1993
discussing the issue of porn take a
listen because she sounds far more
right-wing than almost any conservative
on this issue today
those are actual acts that isn't what
quote unquote offends somebody Charlie
if you heard a woman screaming in the
Next Room by being bounced off walls by
a man she lives with
are you offended
I mean that isn't what you say to
yourself you're experiencing the
enactment of an abuse you're witnessing
it you feel it you hear her scream you
think I've got to do something about
this I'm saying
I mean that's what I experience when I
see pornography a woman is being hurt
here
she's being violated
she's being used
and on top of it I get to know that
someone's enjoying this
I mean on top of of her humiliation
there's going to be men experiencing
their own sexuality and this being
protected as a constitutional right and
called a form of entertainment
based how can I how can I vote for that
radical feminist because that radical
feminist is much more right-wing this
radical left-wing feminist she's a
leftist in she's Catherine McKinnon okay
she is much more right-wing
on very important issues than pretty
much any Republican today
pathetic represents a total failure a
total collapse of anything even
resembling conservatism over the last 30
years
and the point she's making is a really
important one
even Beyond porn
even Beyond porn because what she's
saying is look
if you were just sitting in your in your
home and you heard your neighbor
is some woman who's your neighbor making
the sounds that you would hear in lots
of if not most pornography
you'd probably rush over there you say
hey is everything everything okay are
you all right lady it sounds like you're
being no no okay all right maybe maybe
she's okay but maybe she's not
pornography can be very you know because
pornography is appealing to your your
most base sort of
despicable fantasies right it's not it's
not appealing to your higher loves it's
appealing to your lust so it's it is
representing generally sort of abusive
Behavior
you would be concerned about that you
would feel even if you were just hearing
it in real life you you would you would
feel like you were somehow you had an
obligation to do something
so why don't people feel that way with
pornography
pornography always represents an abuse
even if it's not violent pornography it
is a woman being used or not being
treated as a full human being but just
being used as a kind of slab of meat to
appeal to the to the basis desires of
the audience and being thrown out like
trash and being paid very little and
everyone knows everyone's heard the
horrible stories of abuse in the
pornography industry so why is it that
you would feel bad and sort of morally
responsible if it were happening in the
room next door but you don't feel bad
and morally responsible when you're
getting your jollies looking at it on a
computer screen
this is where the issue becomes much
bigger than just pornography actually
you feel that when you are
when you are experiencing life in in a
virtual world that you don't have moral
responsibilities oh it's just online you
see this on Twitter the way people talk
to one another on Twitter
is is wrong and and impolite and frankly
sinful a lot of the time you would never
speak that way to someone in real life
but you feel like you can speak that way
to someone on the internet because
Twitter is not real life
Twitter's not real live the internet's
not real live porn's not real life
except it actually is
it's life you're there you're there
doing it you are you are responsible for
your actions even in the virtual world
and we've got to resolve this issue
right now because we are going to be
living more and more of our lives in the
virtual world we don't go shopping that
much anymore we just click buttons
online we don't see our friends in
person nearly as much anymore we do it
online or on FaceTime or on our phones
or on chat or on text
we don't we don't get married and have
sex as much anymore you can see those
numbers plummeting what do we do instead
we sext we well I don't okay I'm not
sexting anybody but I'm not doing listen
I'm married I'm a happily married man
okay but what do what do young people do
the ones who are not getting married the
ones who are not the ones who
statistically aren't even having sex
anymore what are they doing they're
living their lives online and they're
having this virtual connection
and so then if we have if we believe
that we don't have any moral
responsibilities in the virtual Realm
then we're just throwing morality out
the window
in terms of how we treat our co-workers
in terms of how we treat our family and
our friends in terms of how we treat yes
the issue of sex in terms of how we
treat our countrymen in terms of
you are morally responsible for these
things you are you are doing it whether
you want to pretend like your body
doesn't matter at all like you're just
it's only an intellectual action it's
only a an action that's happening in
your mind
but you have responsibility for that as
well okay I can't believe
that that the rat the radical feminists
are much smarter on this point than the
conservatives are
conservatives got to wise up
gotta wise up on this because this is
the future as we move ever closer toward
the metaverse
you are going to want to make sure that
we recognize that the moral
responsibilities we all have toward
ourselves and toward each other whether
it's in Oculus or whether it's in real
life
because it's all real life it's all real
life whether it no matter how much it
involves your body it is real life
speaking of women and sex Nancy Pelosi
is coming out strongly
in favor of abortion ahead of the
midterms there is a conflict within the
Republican party there are those in the
party that think life begins at the
candlelight dinner the night before
and and and and these people are in
defiance of that right they're in
defiance of that because they're saying
whatever they're saying about it so
that's that's what you're seeing there
but we are united in our support for
women's right to choose
okay that's a funny line these
Republicans they think that life begins
you know at the candle at dinner you
know before you go it's so crazy these
crazy Republicans every sperm is sacred
like what was it Monty Python used to
sing except
Republicans don't really believe that
life begins at the candle at dinner they
don't believe that life begins at the
level of the gonads
the sperm or the Egg they say that life
begins at conception
this is the real hold up for the
Democrats on all these kind of silly
lines
obviously life begins at conception
that's the definition of conception
that's why there's a word for it
conception refers to the beginning of
Life
when it is conceived
so no it's it's pretty clear and no
matter what sort of debates people want
to have about abortion the Democrats can
never get past this this fact and so
they've got to just have these kind of
glib jokes and these dismissals
and oh never mind and these distractions
and nothing to see here
they're trying to do it on on the
immigration issue as well oh no this is
human trafficking this is awful what
they're doing but then there's the
obvious
Next Step which is
well hold on you're you're doing the
same thing at a not just a slightly
higher scale at many orders of magnitude
higher scale
so what we can't we can't get past that
sometimes these issues are really really
simple when does Life begin life begins
at conception that's the definition
well what's what's wrong with illegal
immigration illegal immigration is
illegal it's not that complicated
okay why can't the foreigners do
whatever they want in America because
they're not citizens be as Citizens are
citizens and there's a clear there are
really clear distinctions to be had here
folks and the Democrats can Giggle and
be glib but because they have no
arguments here ultimately they've just
got to suppress the debate on this and
attack their political opponents in as a
matter of rhetoric and physically
increasingly as well you know our
mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan enter promo
code Knowles podcast to get one month
for free
let's get to the voicemail back first
question
Michael I am uh Adjunct professor at two
colleges in California and uh I want to
know how you would handle this one in an
interview
I was asked the question of how do you
deal with your white privilege and being
a you know middle aged white male I'm
just wondering how would you handle that
question thank you
how do I deal with my white privilege
well I worked as hard as I could to do
to do as well as I could on the SAT
because I knew that in college
admissions I would be discriminated
against uh because of my white privilege
I made sure that I watched every single
word that I ever said because I knew
that if I ever said anything that could
be in any way even implausibly
misinterpreted as somehow racist I knew
that my entire life could be ruined
because of my white privilege I made
sure that when I was insulted by the
entire culture and by the state and by
the government because of my skin color
I made sure never to you know speak up
too loudly against that because I knew
that that would somehow paradoxically be
called racist as well and then then my
life could be ruined for it so how did I
deal with my white privilege you know
with the spirit of resignation and the
recognition that suffering can be a
sanctifying fact I guess that's how
that's how One deals with white
privilege these days as we all should
deal with the various difficulties that
one faces in life you know a spirit of
resignation kiss it up to God try to
make things a little bit better and
don't complain next question
hello Michael this is uh Eduardo
Hernandez I'm calling from Puerto Rico
uh I'm a medical doctor I'm a
conservative because not everybody over
here are crazy Lefty lunatics uh who
think the world runs on rainbows and
good intentions
um I wanted to introduce you to the
dunning-kruger effect see if you ever
heard about it if you know about it and
what do you think about the whole
concept and how can you relate it to
current politics I'm very interested in
listening to you about this and
I wanted to say hello too big fan
all right great question yes I am
familiar to some degree with the Dunning
Kruger effect as I understand it the
dunning-kruger effect is this warping of
self-perception such that people who are
at the low end of skill or intelligence
or aptitude uh tend to overestimate
their skill and intelligence and
aptitude and also that people at the
high end of skill and intelligence and
aptitude tend to underestimate
how skilled and smart they are at
certain things
and what do I think of it I think it's
obviously true
this is obviously true we all know this
in our daily lives right it's always the
people who are the most
strident yelling you know not only can
they not change their minds but they
can't even change the subject those
people and the ones who tend to to
utterly dismiss anything that anyone has
to say other than themselves those
people tend to be a little bit Dumber
right and those people tend to be more
ignorant a a a wiser
um a way to operate in the world would
be one of humility to recognize that
every man is my master every man is my
teacher I can learn something from from
everybody on Earth that's obviously true
and I've seen the other side of it too
people who are some of the most
intelligent capable people I've ever met
do tend to be not only humble which is
good you want to cultivate a spirit of
humility but do actually sometimes
vastly underestimate their uh their
skill and intelligence that's certainly
true but it's
you see it it's much more common in in
the first sense that dumb people tend to
think they're a lot smarter than they
are to oversimplify it and
it's it's really dangerous there's
there's that great bit of advice which
is that it's better to be silent and
thought to be an idiot rather than to
open your mouth and prove it it's and
it's another thing I remember it pretty
distinctly in my early 20s
this happened to me a little bit in
college but really in my early 20s I
had this
bomb go off in my head where I was
reading a lot you know I try to read at
night have a cigar or read and as I'm
reading just these kind of different
smatterings of books I realized that I
don't know anything
and it's not false modesty it's just
a little dose of humility I realized oh
my gosh not only do I I know
statistically nothing
but
I I only have even a hint of an inkling
of of how little I don't know
you know the kind of Don Rumsfeld known
knowns known unknowns and unknown
unknowns the unknown unknowns are the
scariest one because when you know what
you know that's fine it's usually pretty
small amount of things and then the
known unknowns you can say okay well I
know that there's such a thing as
welding I just don't know how to do it
but I know that they're okay and then
unknown unknowns
would be it's the largest category of
all it's all the things that you don't
know that you don't even know that you
don't know and so a spirit of humility
is very important if for no other reason
then at least you won't look like such a
dummy okay next one
Michael in relation to your interview
the other day with the Fox News host who
got fired for not taking the vaccine
it made me
wonder about something my friends talk
about quite frequently who are super
conservative and that's about controlled
opposition I hear this pointed at Fox
News a lot especially because of them
calling Florida but I've even heard it
levied at a daily wire and Ben Shapiro
by by more we'll call them rabid
conservatives can you give me your take
on controlled opposition and
what that means and who the players are
in our modern society who could be that
absolutely it's really really good
question there are two kinds of
controlled opposition
the the one version of controlled
opposition is that you know there's a
shadowy cabal of like five people in a
room who are just pick up the phone and
they say tell this person not to say
that or tell this person to do that or
whatever you know it kind of goes down
the chain and then that's what happens
uh that I think is I'm not saying that
has never happened anywhere you know the
the reason that conspiracy theories can
gain ground is because there are
conspiracies so I'm not saying that that
doesn't happen a lot but the the much
more prevalent version of controlled
opposition is uh is not really Guided by
any one person at all it's Guided by a
structure and a system in which there
are incentives and disincentives to
raising certain ideas or making certain
arguments and so a really good example
of this would be uh social media right
on social media you can say certain
things and you can't say certain things
and you you Rec you remember this during
covid right during covid there were
moments where I had episodes of my show
taken down because I said true things
perfectly unobjectionable true things
that the prevailing ruling class would
not tolerate so they took my Showdown on
the biggest social media Platforms in
the country fortunately I have the daily
wire and so I could say on the show okay
this is being censored here we've
sometimes put a censorship bar over it
but go on over to daily wire you get the
full story
which I think would be some evidence
that we are not controlled opposition at
the daily wire but but we're we're
subject to the same forces the same
incentives and disincentives as anybody
else and so the the important thing here
is to give yourself more leverage such
that you're not at the whims and the
mercy of that ruling structure okay and
so this is something daily wires tried
to do
very intentionally
we are trying to build an entirely
separate ecosystem that's why we're
selling razors that's why we're making
movies that's why we're increasingly
sending people over to become members on
The Daily wire because then we're less
vulnerable to the forces of this kind of
superstructure that that tries to shrink
the Overton window and move the realm of
acceptable discourse very far to the
left okay and that's what we have to do
you've got to be able to have your own
platform ideally you've got to be able
to have your own servers in case let's
say Amazon web services wants to take
you down you've got to be able to have
your own wealth
so that you can fight back so that you
can't be just absolutely crushed by by a
much more powerful and wealthy and
better financed source of forces
right it's it's it's much more
complicated so when you're talking about
a cable news channel yeah cable news is
one I think a lot of the cable news
channels
intentionally don't don't want to
promote particularly conservative
content but also they're they're very
firmly within a superstructure that
won't permit them to either that's why
we need Alternatives next question
hello Mr Knowles hope you're doing well
I got a question here for you
what if we made a punishment worse than
the death penalty now I bring this
question to you because in a previous
voicemail bag you were kind of talking
about how if we made the punishment for
rape and murder the same the death
penalty for example then the rapist
would have an incentive to kill the
victim which would be horrible so we
said okay you know we're not going to do
that we're going to have a lesser
punishment for rape and then a worse
punishment for murder
I think this makes sense however I think
there's a better solution so here it is
what if we keep rape
at the death penalty and created a worse
punishment for murder
now what what would this entail I would
say is torture on the books is that is
that something that we could do you know
of course we would have to throw away
the cruel and unusual punishment Clause
but I don't know maybe it's something
worth to consider appreciate it
a fair enough suggestion but I I would
not consider it too strongly one because
you would have to amend the Constitution
as you say to get rid of cruel cruel and
unusual punishment prohibitions
um which I think would be virtually
impossible and ill-advised uh but
two because torture is not
does not seem to Jive very well with
Justice you know the reason that we we
execute certain criminals and the reason
we punish all criminals there are three
reasons there is the deterrent effect
there's the rehabilitative effect and
then there's retribution retributive
Justice
all of which is a little different than
say Vengeance or a sort of vindictive uh
infliction of pain okay and and so
you've got two scenarios here
to preserve
um a an incentive for rapists not to
kill their victims you could say all
right we're going to kill the murderers
and we're going to give life in prison
or a long prison sentence to rapists or
castration to rapists or you say we're
going to kill the rapists and we're
going to draw and quarter the murderers
uh I think life in prison or castrate
and and castration for uh rapists would
be sufficient
I don't I don't think that I would upend
the Constitution and Institute a regime
of torture just to to squeeze a little
more punishment out of people who commit
bad crimes okay one last uh written
question before we get to the member
block from Daniel Michael my wife and I
got married earlier this summer we're
still in that wonderful honeymoon phase
my question is this in your marriage how
do you go about deciding which arguments
you are willing to contend with and
which ones you will let go on one hand I
don't want to constantly argue about
everything on the other I don't want to
be a one of those cuckold husbands who
don't stand up for what they believe is
right I think there's a pretty big gray
area between the foundational questions
openness to Children raising the family
of the faith versus the trivial which
movie to watch what to have for dinner
Etc but where do you draw the line how
do you make the distinction any other
marital advice for a young couple would
be welcome thanks I would be really
traditional about this I would throw
feminism out the window and you'll have
a much better life
so the way that that we do it sweet
little Lisa and I is I I do reluctantly
act as the head of household and it's
usually she has to she has to prod me to
do it you know we'll be saying where do
you want to go to dinner you want
Chinese I don't know you want Italian I
don't know you want Mexican and she'll
send you back
this old Genesis 3 make a decision let's
go you know same thing with watching a
movie or whatever because men generally
don't really want to be tyrants you know
insisting on their will all the time men
generally want to sit on the couch and
eat potato chips and not have to make
decisions but the way it's set up you
know if you're a Christian then you know
you're the man is the head of the
household and so practically speaking
we hash out all of the questions I don't
just this especially happens with
um decorations in our home I really care
a lot about Aesthetics and so we'll talk
about it we'll talk about it at length
and come to a kind of no I don't think
this is good no I think this looks more
beautiful no this color is better this
will hash it out ultimately if if we
really come to an impasse I I will make
a decision very often I defer to my wife
sometimes I don't defer to my wife okay
as a practical matter on most decisions
certainly within the home and a lot
within the family I defer to my wife
entirely but I think if you still have
that structure of the man as the head of
the household it makes it it makes
things much clearer and more orderly
okay the rest of the show is continuing
now if you don't want to miss it
well obviously you don't want to miss it
but if you're not a member you've got to
click the link in the description and
join us we have not only some more
questions from you because it will do a
little bit of an extended mailbag thanks
to it being Friday but we've also got
the uh fake headlines so my producers
have come up with five headlines of the
week that they believe I have not seen
one of them is fake you and I have to
guess which the fake one is okay we'll
see over at the member block
[Music]
[Music]
all right